hilarion معي كبير
المستشارين الاقتصاديين في Allianz Memory لقد بدأت في
التفكير في هذا من حيث
كيفية سماع دقيقة واحدة لشيء واحد وأنت تتفق
معهم في اللحظة التالية التي تسمع فيها
الحجة المعاكسة وتتفق
معهم لذلك أسألك  السؤال
سوف أسأل ما هو مستوى الوفيات الذي نحن على
استعداد لقبوله ، لذا فإن هذا صعب حقًا
لأنه يعيش هناك
سبل عيش أو إذا كنت تعيش في
دولة نامية فقيرة ، فهناك خطر
الموت من الفيروس أو الموت من الجوع
لذا ، إنها نظرة صعبة حقًا ،
فالواقع أننا
نفتح الضغط على الانفتاح بشدة ،
لكن دعنا نركز على معرفة أن هناك خسارة
لا نعرف ريتشارد ولكننا
سنجري تجربة طبيعية ضخمة في
الولايات المتحدة وحدها  سنحصل على ولايات قبل
المبادئ التوجيهية الفيدرالية ، الولايات التي تقف وراء
الإرشادات الفيدرالية ونبقى على نفس الخط ،
وسنحصل على الكثير من البيانات التي نحتاجها
للحكم ليس فقط على المخاطر التي نتعامل
معها في اختبار TOEIC فيما يتعلق بالعدوى ولكن
كيف يمكن للأشخاص  سيتصرف le كيف ستتصرف الشركات
لا أعرف
الإجابة الصحيحة ولكني أعلم أنه
تم اتخاذ قرار سياسي وعلينا
التعلم وجمع البيانات والتكيف بسرعة
إذا كنا سنحصل على هذا التوازن بشكل صحيح
بمرور الوقت ، لأنه بمرور
الوقت سوف نفهم الأمر بشكل صحيح ،
سوف نتعايش مع الفيروس لفترة من الوقت
ترى أن هذا شيء آخر
سنكون حقًا في
استنتاج بشأن هذه الفكرة الخاصة بنا.
سيتعين علينا التعايش مع الفيروس
حتى يكون هناك لقاح بعيد
المنال وهذا يجهد كل
تفكير اقتصادي مجتمعي
التفكير الجحيم يمكن أن يتصرف الثلاثة من
وجهة نظرك في وئام حتى يتمكنوا إذا كان
لديك  لقاح كما أشرت
للتو أو إذا كان لديك
اختبار وتتبع معقدان للغاية ، فلن نصل إلى
هناك سريعًا ، لذلك سنقوم بالتخبط ،
لا تفكر في الأمر على أنه إعادة فتح سلسة ،
سنقوم بإعادة فتحها ، وسنتعلم
قد نضطر إلى إغلاق أجزاء من
الاقتصاد  لن يكون من
الصعب جدًا على صانع القرار
إغلاق الاقتصاد بأكمله مرة أخرى ،
فستحتاج إلى إيقاظ شديد للعدوى
، ولهذا السبب أراد خبراء الصحة منا
أن نسير على ما
يرام ، لكن دعنا نأخذ المثال الوحيد في
كوريا الجنوبية حيث كان هناك تفشي
باعتراف الجميع  اندلاع العنقودية المتوقفة
حول النوادي الليلية إذا بدأنا نرى
شيئًا كهذا حولك ، قل
مترو الأنفاق في نيويورك أو استخدام مترو الأنفاق ،
فأنت مدين بأن الحاكم أندرو
كومو لن يكون لديه أي خيار فيما
يتعلق بأقصد بغض النظر عن التأثير الاقتصادي
الذي تراه أنت '  لقد بدأت الأمر مرة أخرى
حول تأرجح البندول للخلف
وللأمام بين مختلف
الأبطال ، نعم ، السؤال هو
ما حجم التأرجحات والأمل
بمرور الوقت أن تصبح التقلبات تبدو صغيرة
، والمثال المخيف حقًا هو
فكرة سنغافورة التي فكرت فيها ولعقها
ثم كان لا بد من إغلاقه تمامًا حتى تتمكن
كوريا على الأقل من عزلها حتى تتمكن من
الاختبار أو التتبع ويمكن أن تستمر في العمل كما
تعلم ، أعتقد أن هذا كما اعتدنا  عش
في هذا اللغز المتطور حقًا
الذي تم تجميعه ،
لقد أفسدت العدوى كل شيء الآن
نحاول إعادة تجميع اللغز
معًا وليس لدينا كل
القطع ، لذا لن يكون مناسبًا
حتى لو أخبرك أن انظر إلى الصين الصين
فتحت 80 90 في المائة ، ومع ذلك ، فقد
انخفض النشاط الاقتصادي في أبريل ، لماذا
لأن العالم ينفتح في
مسألة غير متزامنة ، هذه الدولة ،
تفتح الولايات المتحدة
أمرًا غير متزامن ، لذا سيكون هناك
الكثير من المطبات على طول الطريق ، وآمل أن
أفعل  قل آمل أنه لا يوجد شيء
محدد مسبقًا بشأن هذا البندول
سيصبح صغيراً في تقلباته ، لقد بدأت
في التفكير في هذا ، ألم أقصد أن
الجميع كان يدرك أنه يجب التفكير
فيه ولكنك بلورته ، لقد أدركت في
وقت مبكر أن هذا النقاش الفاوستي  على
عكس مناقشة Falchi ، فإن هذه
الصفقة الفوستية التي يتعين علينا
القيام بها هي غير
مريحة للغاية لدرجة أننا نجعلها
في منطقتنا
ولكننا لا نفعل ذلك أبدًا.  xtent صادفته
في الثمانينيات عندما عملت ريتشارد
على حصة هشة وفاشلة ،
وهذه هي الحقيقة التي لم
نختبرها أبدًا على مستوى الاقتصاد العالمي
ولم نختبر أبدًا
مستوى الاقتصادات المتقدمة ، لذا سيكون هناك
أن يكون هناك الكثير من الأحكام ، فمن
الصعب حقًا أن تعرف أن شعوري الداخلي
هو أن الناس كانوا ساذجين للغاية بشأن
مدى سهولة إعادة فتح هذا
الاقتصاد ، حيث أنهم نوعًا ما
ستضغط على المفتاح وسيعود كل
شيء إليه  تبين أن مشكلاتهم الصحية
هناك مشكلات اقتصادية
وهي مشكلات سلوكية لا نعرف
كيف سيكون رد فعل الناس أعرف
أن ريتشارد أحد أفراد الأسرة الآن ، والبعض منهم
على استعداد لإشراك البعض الآخر
وليسوا من نفس العائلة.
سافعل